am morgen nach dem kanzler trainer legt
armin laschet jetzt nach 13 uhr will der
cdu kanzler kandidat sein sofortprogramm
vorstellen die ersten schritte die ja
als kanzler von deutschland unternehmen
will und die schauen wir uns jetzt ganz
genau an das lasche sofortprogramm
laschet setzt also auf mehr geld im
portemonnaie
steuerentlastungen für eltern und
alleinerziehende
steuerliche förderung beim hausbau
anhebung wohngeld mehr geld für
pflegende angehörige habe mir das noch
mal als grafik für sie aufbereitet
bessere steuerentlastung steuerliche
entlastung bei kinderbetreuungskosten
minijob grenze die soll auch erhöht
werden ja exklusive informationen die
uns vorliegen ja selbst auch aus innere
sicherheit mehr videoüberwachung und
härtere strafen nach attacken auf
polizisten und ganz entscheidend er
möchte die einrichtung eines nationalen
sicherheitsrats im kanzleramt
chef julian reichelt ist bei uns julian
nationaler sicherheitsrat sowie es aus
amerika aus den usa beispielsweise
kennen das klingt gewichtig ist aber
letztendlich weiterer arbeitskreis ein
weiterer arbeitskreis wäre es nicht wenn
man diesen nationalen sicherheitsrat der
hier in dem papier was bis jetzt
exklusiv vorliegt wenn man den
tatsächlich so lebt wie in den usa er
hat armin laschet hat mit peter neumann
einen wirklich fabelhaften man einen
fabelhaften kenner des internationalen
extremismus und terrorismus allein das
große problem was damit lasse derzeit
hat und das stellt tatsächlich die
glaubwürdigkeit dieses sicherheitspakt
ist für mich erst mal ein bisschen in
frage wir sind heute zwei tage nach dem
zwanzigsten jahrestag von nine eleven am
11 september hat armin laschet seine
große rede auf dem csu-parteitag
gehalten wen hat er dabei nicht erwähnt
als er über nine eleven gesprochen hat
islamisten wer für diese taten
verantwortlich ist hat armin laschet
dort nicht gesagt armin laschet spricht
seit wochen bemerkenswerterweise kaum
noch über islamismus er sagt dann immer
internationaler terrorismus armin
laschet meidet dieses wort im wahlkampf
ist sowieso kaum noch die rede von
islamismus
laschet hat gestern noch einmal zu
bedrohungslagen in deutschland gesagt
die größte gefahr für deutschland ist
der terrorismus von rechts das mag so
sein das ist ja auch die einschätzung
des verfassungsschutzes nur die größte
globale bedrohung ist natürlich der tore
der islamistische terrorismus und
natürlich braucht man kein
sicherheitsrat in dem man nicht mehr
islamismus sagen darf ein sicherheitsrat
bringt nur dann was wenn der der der
verantwortliche der chef der anführer
dieses sicherheitsrats und das muss ja
armin laschet seien bereit ist über die
themen auch wirklich zu sprechen und
über das thema islamismus verliert armin
laschet nicht mal mehr an einen level
nicht mal mehr am elfter september auch
nur ein wort deswegen wird die große
frage seid will armin laschet in seinem
sicherheitsrat überhaupt hören wer uns
da bedroht oder darf es nur um gruppen
gehen dir gerne erwähnt in diesem
kontext aber bitte nicht um islamisten
wir wissen armin laschet bei dem thema
migration
einwanderung der islam in deutschland
sehr sensibel sehr zurückhaltend
offenbar möchte jetzt nicht mal mehr
muslime dadurch verstehen dass der
islamismus sagt damit wird er den
muslimen noch nicht recht denn moderate
muslime hassen den islamismus armin
laschet traut sich nicht mehr das wort
zu sagen um das ist in seinem
sicherheits kreis im nationalen
sicherheitsrat sehr oft gehen wird da
muss armin laschet jetzt erstmal
vorlegen bevor man ihnen den nationalen
sicherheitsrat dann auch wirklich
abnimmt das papier julian liegt vor dir
und da geht es unter anderem um das
interessiert die wählerinnen und wähler
ja besonders darum was bleibt in unseren
taschen umfeld sollte armin laschet kann
durch lernen wie schatz daraus also dass
dieses papier das sofortprogramm zur
bundestagswahl wie es hier heißt
beinhaltet denkmal sechs fette pakete
also da hat armin laschet sollte es ins
kanzleramt schaffen sich schon mal
ordentlich was aufgelegt und um es ins
kanzleramt zu schaffen gibt es das sieht
man aus diesem paket ein ganz klares
neues konzept das ist schon immer im
wahlkampf gab und es lässt sich in drei
worten zusammenfassen geschenke
geschenke geschenke mehr geld für eltern
und kinder wir werden das
ehegattensplitting für alle halten einen
gesetzentwurf einbringen um die grund
einen grundfreibetrag der kinder auf der
auf denen der erwachsenen anzuheben und
das kindergeld zu erhöhen also mehr geld
für familien da mal auf muss jemand
bezahlen wer steht hier nicht drin mehr
geld für alleinerziehende
wir unterstützen allein erziehende
eltern in ihrer besonders
herausfordernden situation und werden
den entlastungsbetrag für
alleinerziehende auf 5000 euro erhöhen
also mehr geld für alleinerziehende
gucken wir kurz wer das bezahlt da steht
ja noch nicht kommt sicher noch
eigenheim für familien wir werden den
ländern ermöglichen einen freibetrag bei
der grund der werkstatt von 250.000 euro
wachsen plus 100000 euro pro kind beim
erstmaligen erwerb selbstgenutzten
wohnraums zu gewähren das wäre eine
enorme steuerentlastung ich schaue mal
ganz kurz vorher steht wer das bezahlt
besteht hier noch nicht wird sicher
nachgeliefert mehr hilfe für pflegende
angehörige familiengerechtes wohnen
ermöglichen vorfahrt für kinderbetreuung
beschleunigungs paket und dann gibt es
hier noch das entlastungspaket
entlastung für kleine und mittlere
einkommen wir werden kleine und mittlere
einkommen bei der einkommensteuer
entlasten dazu werden wir den
arbeitnehmer-pauschbetrag auf
1250 erhöhen das müssen wir uns im
detail noch mal angucken bisher wollte
armin laschet keine konkrete
steuersenkung das könnte man da jetzt
aber doch als steuersenkung einordnen
damit hätte markus söder sich ein
bisschen zumindest durchgesetzt der
steuersenkungs steuerentlastung wollte
interessanterweise das wundert mich ein
bisschen stehen hier ganz viele punkte
drin mit denen armin laschet gestern vor
elf millionen zuschauern massiv hätte
punkten können und er verrät sie erst
heute in einer pressekonferenz das
wundert mich ein bisschen aber auch bei
diesen entlastung hier steht auch mehr
im portemonnaie für schüler mehr
portemonnaie von elterngeld nur für
china belastet verspricht mehr
taschengeld mehr portmann nehmen für
schüler studenten und neben aber die
minijob grenze werden wir sofort von 450
auf 550 euro pro monat an dem sicher
gute idee wer bezahlt steht hier nicht
ja also das ist ein fettes paket werde
ich das auch die antwort darauf warum
gestern abend warum erst einmal noch
nicht darüber gesprochen hat weil die
frage natürlich gekommen war von den
kontrahenten das kann natürlich sein die
frage das muss man aber sagen das ist so
oft im wahlkampf ja man sagt ja im
wahlkampf werden wähler mit ihrem
eigenen steuer geld bestochen wie das
hier gegenfinanziert ist das ist
logischerweise die frage an der sich die
seriosität dieses paket entscheidet die
wird jetzt in den nächsten stunden
kommen ich prophezeie die spd wird das
als allererstes aufmachen die rechnung
dass hier geld auch an wird aber nicht
gesagt wird wie das bezahlt wird und da
wird es dann wieder interessant denn die
spd sagte sie möchte für höhere
einkommen tatsächlich steuern erhöhen
und damit dinge bezahlen entlastungen an
anderer seite bezahlen das geht hier
daraus nicht hervor wird der spannende
punkt armin laschet wird es vermutlich
noch erklären
[Musik]